when a user goes to a search engine and
searches for something commercial like a
good or a service then besides the
regular organic
results uh you also the user also sees
advertisements you can think of it as
the search engine connecting uh people
who want uh to buy a good or service
with sellers who want to sell
it it's a matching in that
sense
um and uh I'm sure most of you are aware
of this but just a kind of brief
background how do advertisers bid on
Google to get their ads shown at the
correct relevant places uh and I'm going
to call this the traditional bidding and
auction setup because I'm going to next
talk about auto bidding um so imagine
you are a math tutor in Berkeley you
come to the search engine and say well
here are the keywords I'm interested in
and here are my bids for those keywords
so if uh if a user is searching for math
tutor within the Berkeley region then
please show my ad and I'm willing to pay
up to $5 uh the user kind of clicks
through and so on right so the
advertisers submits a whole kind of a
table of keywords and
bids and then during kind of online when
users actually come to the search engine
and search for I need help with math
then uh various advertisers who bid on
such relevant keywords get kind of uh
triggered at this point
and a few of them are shown to this user
and we do this with an auction um so um
that auction has to consider the uh the
the quality of the match over there of
this particular Advertiser and this user
as well as the bids that kind of reflect
how much this Advertiser thinks it's
valuable to be
sure um and for now we'll just think of
this auction as a kind of second price
auction uh which factors in the bids but
also some kind of quality
scores and we won't go much into auction
design in the beginning uh there's a
whole area on ad auction design you must
have heard of things like GSP and vcg
and so on uh and I'll add one more
caviat that there's a lot of other
considerations which go into building
the system it's not just kind of the the
bid or the revenue uh we have to worry a
lot about the user experience and the
kind of match quality because that's
finally where the value is being created
as well as the ROI that go to our
advertising
Partners this is how much value they get
out of the money
that's so it's not simply kind of a
revenue
maximization or why run an auction uh no
need to tell this audience it's a
welfare and price Discovery mechanism in
this kind of Highly Dynamic
decentralized setting with a very large
set of heterogeneous goods from the math
tutor to Fir and the demand and Supply
change over
time and so now with this kind of
background you can imagine that the
auctions are mostly stateless in the
sense that when a query comes in we can
kind of do all this process and show an
ad and you can do all this in kind of in
parallel across all these queries um but
what I'm going to talk about now is how
all of these auctions kind of tie into
each other through some higher level
bidder
constraints so so what are these right
so here's an example of a very kind of
traditional bidder constraint here's
this math tutor who puts in the
targeting with the bid table puts in
certain
bids um let's say the targeting is for
math tutor and there are kind of 500
potential clicks for the month and puts
in a bid saying I'm willing to pay up to
a dollar per
click um but then they also put in a
budget for various reasons and the
budget could be $100 per month and if
you do the math then 500 times something
like $1 is much greater than 100
so so this is kind of mismatched and so
that's a higher level bidding constraint
that we have to somehow
incorporate um and we can do it in
various ways we can think of the
targeting as being too
broad and the platform can kind of
figure out what are the better places
for this ad to show or the bidding is
too
high
um and in a lot of earlier work uh which
is reflected in this chapter with nikil
Dean which is this uh wonderful book uh
we formulated this question as an online
budgeted allocation question simply
online matching question uh together
with uh the original paper together with
Amin Sai and Vijay vazirani and
UMES and there the question was you have
all these kind of think of these bit
tables and the budget constraints and
these queries are arriving online what
is the best way to kind of uh do this
bipartite allocation so that no one goes
above budget but you still get a high
enough value overall because you can't
simply run the auction based on the
original um and there's a lot of
interesting followup models and
algorithms from a whole kind of whole
bunch of people here
um uh so so in this talk I'm going to
talk about something different but this
is the kind of background uh so in this
talk we'll talk about decentralized
allocation algorithms so this work over
here was kind of centralized as the
platform decides at this point given the
budget constraints and amount of spend
who should be matched now we just going
to talk about a completely
decentralized allocation algorithm via
this notion of
automating and please stop me for any
questions so so that's kind of the
background of the talk
um and uh let's let's let's talk about
what what is automating right so I just
explain the kind of traditional form of
bidding which is that the advertiser
sends to the platform very fine grain
bidding tables so it basically a table
of which keyword I'm interested in and
what's the bid for that keyword and
possibly a budget and some other kind of
constraints in in auto
bidding uh The Advertiser sends to kind
of the sense to an so there's an auto
bidding layer in between the advertiser
and the auction platform
and The Advertiser sends to the auto
bidder some very high level goals and
constraints instead of this very
detailed uh bid table um and it's the
auto bidder's job to convert those goals
and constraints into the per auction bid
kind of at auction time and the job of
the auto bidder is to kind of
bid uh optimally for this particular
advertising so the kind of entire
picture is that there are lots of
advertisers and each one has an as an
autoing agent which bids into the
auctions what do these goals and
constraints look like so one of them we
already saw so product called budget
optimizers in that the advertiser says
but I just want to maximize my number of
clicks I get in this month and my
constraint is this budget and you figure
it out how to
buid another one which is a bit more
interesting and this is what we look at
for the rest of the talk uh is
this this autoing product called Target
CPA CPA stands for cost per
acquisition acquisition is another name
for a sale
so okay so in in that product The
Advertiser comes and says maximize the
number of conversions I get from my
Campaign which is conversion is a sale
finally uh and subject to this
constraint that the average cost per
conversion is no more than my
target okay so basically the uh the math
tutor comes and says like you know
maximize the number of leads I get for
students uh but my average cost per
student should be no more than uh
$20 and what's kind of important here is
it's an average cost and not a marginal
cost and then there are more kind of uh
more fancier products as well we won't
go into that so we we'll talk about
Target CPA and I'll kind of again
reemphasize it's this kind of simple
program maximize my number of
conversions okay so conversion is also
is another term for acquisition or sale
sorry that so maximize my number of
conversions subject
to my spend is no more than target times
the number of
conversions simply my or my average
spend is no more times this
Target and so T is the number that the
advertiser tells gives the automator
and this is kind of a very nice system
because the advertiser can focus on the
performance and take higher level
decisions and kind of leave these very
uh detailed bidding to the auto bidding
agent and in this talk we're going to
talk about two kind of high level
questions number one is how would you
design such an automating agent so how
to bid as an auto bidding agent for a
single Advertiser once you're given
these goals and constraints
and uh then the second question is the
matching question which is that when all
these Auto biders are competing against
each other through the
auctions uh what will be the global
welfare um and does that in equilibrium
basically and does that welfare depend
on the underlying auction
design so so here's the first question
which is basically an optimization
question so so in the tcpa world an
Advertiser comes to you and says
maximize my conversion subject to my
average cost is no more than Target uh
in this paper with gagan Agarwal and
Ashwin
Bandu we gave a more General framework
which kind of captures all these
products and say Here's this integer
program so which captures this Auto
biding question so what are these
different different terms so I indexes
all the different add opportunities that
this bidder could buy XI says should you
buy the aat click or ath item and VI is
the value for the ath
click and then there are a bunch of
constraints you could have multiple
constraints like a Target constraint a
budget constraint and so on each of
these constraints the left hand side is
the expected spend so whether you bought
the item I or not and then what is the
cost per click of the item I we add that
all together that's the expected spend
and then the right hand side of all
these constraints is this kind
of is the constraint where there's a
budget kind of
constraint and then There's a constraint
which is also linear in the XI so
essentially overall all of these
constraints say that it's a constraint
on the
spend where the cap is itself a function
of the bundle that you get okay so let's
see why this kind of makes sense so if
you take the budget Optimizer setting
where you want to maximize clicks so the
vi is just
one and you just have a budget
constraint so you set this you have one
constraint you set the b equal to the
budget and then you don't have any of
this kind of this weird term over here
simply saying my spend is at most the
budget but if you take this more
complicated constraint like Target
CPA remember you want to maximize the
number of conversion
so you can set VI to be the probability
of getting a
conversion if you chose this item I we
call that the conversion
rate and then you have this average cost
constraint so you don't need the B
there's one constraint you don't don't
need the B part of it uh but the average
cost constraint should be something like
uh my total cost divided my divided by
my total conversions is at most this
target so if you read through it then
basically I can just each wi to be kind
of the target times the conversion rate
so you don't have to kind of this is
just a way of saying that this General
LP captures budget constraints captures
Target constraints and a whole lot of
other constraints why don't you put it
two separate
constraints uh these are separate
constraints
sorry okay this is a more General thing
where maybe you come up with a
constraint come up with a product which
has a budget and something else
uh no other
particular but these two examples show
that you either need to b
or
um okay so now given this so now what's
your job is like there are all these add
opportunities and you want to pick a
bundle for this Advertiser
um so suppose you had this integer
program in relax it to a linear program
and you had all the data
including the cost per for every item
which kind of is not really
known um then you could just solve it
and say well there my I optimized it and
I want this set this bundle of
items and our question is well you can't
do that in this online system can a
simple bidding formula lead to the same
outcome so what what's the difficulty
well you can't you don't get to pick you
you don't get to see all the items and
pick a sub
set you can only win an item through the
auction by bidding into the auction and
furthermore you don't get to see those
cpcs which are part of this uh integer
program because you have no idea what
the competition is so it's kind of like
if if you put that way then it's a kind
of a difficult ask that how do you solve
that LP through the bidding in an
auction
um uh but indeed you can do this and
like a moment's thought kind of shows
that you can so here's the the Primal LP
again and then you can kind of use or
you know write the Dual variable the
Dual
LP and you know I won't go into this
linear program but
basically the Dual constraint and the
kind of the complimentary slackness
conditions tell you
that you want to take items where this
constraint is
tight which essentially if you rewrite
turns out to be this that you want to
take all the items and only those items
where the
cost is at most this formula this
formula contains the vi which is known
to you the
value it contains this constraint
constant W and then it contains these
dual
variables so you want to pick all the
items whose cost is at most this and now
if the underlying auction was let's say
a second price auction then all you need
to do is Bid this
amount and then you'll win the item if
the cost is less than that amount and
you won't win the other items which cost
is more than this
amount so the fact
that uh the uh the optimality constraint
turns out to be of this form tells you
that you can actually implement it in a
second price auction very simply by just
bidding this uh this
SP
um and you can generalize this to kind
of all truth truthful
auctions not simply second price where
if you want something less than a cost
you just bid that value but I won't uh I
won't
go so here's kind of the theorem from
the paper is that this bidding formula
I'll call it the uniform bidding formula
is
optimal if and only if the auction is
truthful and of course that bidding
formula depends on the Dual parameters
this is going to become important later
those Al in the formula uh because this
dual parameters depend on what
competition is out there and what are
the other people bidding uh in a
practical system you can learn this from
past data you can have online kind of
algorithms to do
that but it's interesting that you can
now connect the truthfulness the
incentive compatibility of the
underlying auction with the ease of
bidding um
optimally so for example if the
underlying auction was a first price
auction then you don't have such a nice
formula because then you want to kind of
very detailed bidding that
case okay and so the end of this section
like you can kind of forget how we
arrived at this uniform bidding formula
but just remember this for the rest of
the talk that you're going to focus on
this tcpa product and in that case the
bidding formula is a simple we'll call
it a uniform bid
scaling where given the value for an
item which is just the conversion rate
for that item your bid is a multiplier
times that
value uh and that multiplier um is a
number that you come up that's basically
the Dual
variable so you want to bid kind of
proportional to your value which is very
natural of
course so so so so so far we've seen how
to bid on behalf of one Advertiser and
now the question is the matching
question where you have have um
basically multiple agents bidding on
behalf of one Advertiser
each their bids depend on each other
because they're multipliers these
multipliers here depend on what other
biders are bidding and so we have to now
think about the allocation equilibrium
over
here so so at this point it's important
to step back and see kind of where like
how does this connect
to like Advertiser utilities
and if you one way to think about it is
that this these kinds of constraint
based autoing products model the
advertises utilities slightly
differently from the classic setting so
classic setting
is qu linear you want to maximize profit
value Minus cost while these things
including just simply budget
constraint uh we can call them value
maximizing uh objectives where you want
to maximize my value subject to this
kind of average cost constraint or a
budget
constraint and we are going to like for
the rest of the talk take that utility
function or that objective at least as
uh as literally what we want to achieve
after
this if you assume these are the true
objectives how does this change the way
you would design an auction for example
in a classic quasi linear setting we
know that a second price auction vcg
would maximize
welfare does that kind of still hold
here or yeah that's the question we can
look at and that kind of whole
allocation question is tricky because as
I said the bid formulas all depend on
each other so it's uh it's like it's a
kind of a dynamic equilibrium
system in this talk we will look at what
happens in the bidding equilibrium so
given the advertiser inputs basically
the targets as fixed we're just going to
think about what will be the outcome in
the bidding
equilibrium there's a larger question
here which we won't really address in
this stock which is what's the entire
mechanism design over here even under
these kinds of utility functions where
the targets can be strategically
provided or the utility function is
really quasi linear but they're bidding
through these targets uh there's some
preliminary work very interesting work
but uh we uh will just touch upon it at
the end it's really a lot of future work
to be done
here okay so now so with that kind of
caveat right we want to think about the
equilibrium matching and how to measure
its value or
welfare um and so remember this is the
tcpa problem for each Advertiser
maximize my conversion subject to my
average cost per conversion is at most
my
Target and now you can think about
what's a global measure of welfare over
here U each one wants to maximize
conversion so you might think just like
add up all the objective functions add
up all the conversions and that's your
welfare but they do have these different
targets and so it turns out like
different ways to think about it that
this is a good measure of welfare for
efficiency which is the total number of
conversions but Target weighted so each
advertiser's number of conversions gets
weighted by its stated Target
and this as I said it's a very kind of
natural um intuitive definition that is
the target weighted number of
conversions but uh you can come through
it from kind of a more formal way which
is the notion of liquid
welfare U I think one of the authors is
in the room here which was defined for
uh uh for the budgeted setting and the
idea there was that well if you
give if if if a bidder States a very
high value for bunch of items but it's
capped by a very small budget you should
really cap The Welfare by that kind of
budget value because the kind of the
value items
don't are constrained by the willingness
to
pay um and again over here if you think
of the uh the the value as the
U the cap on the spend that a particular
bundle gives you and give keep that as
the cap that's called the liquid welfare
and it turns out to be again precisely
just the target weighted number of
conversions so this is the uh our
measure of efficiency Target weighted
number of
conversions and now we want to ask what
is a good matching and what kind of
matchings do we achieve so what's the
optimal allocation here remember we want
to maximize the target weighted number
of conversions then you should just give
each item
to that bidder who maximizes the
contribution to the sum which is simply
give the item to the bidder which
maximizes its target times its
conversion rate for this
item is that
clear okay so let me say this a bit more
carefully so if you want to maximize
this notion of efficiency in a
matching
then you want to give each item to the
advertiser who maximizes this form this
form is simply my target times my number
of conversions from the side so that's
the optimal allocation if you could
ignore the auction and just simply give
items to
biders as you
want in the
equilibrium each bidder is bidding
according to this formula right which is
the you bit proportional to your uh to
your
value and so you may not achieve this
optimal
allocation because you're not
necessarily giving the item to the
highest value bidder you're giving it to
the highest bid bidder and the bids kind
of depend on each other through this
very complicated
Dynamics and so this is the way we kind
of distinguish across different auctions
which is how much value do you lose in
the bidding
equilibrium and we use this notion which
is called price of Anarchy but simply
the suboptimality in equilibrium versus
the optimal and in the worst case so we
take the worst case instance and see the
optimal efficiency versus the
equilibrium
efficiency and this number is greater
than or equal to one if it's one then
you got a perfectly optimal uh solution
and then the larger it is the worse that
that
solution and in the paper I mentioned we
Prov the following result that if the
underlying auction is a second price
auction or vcg in more general settings
then the price of Anarchy is two which
means that you could be yeah your value
could be half as bad as the optimal
matching and just to kind of reemphasize
that's happening because you cannot
allocate in a centralized manner which
you would like to just give each item to
the one with the highest target times
conversion rate instead you have to
allocate through the auction and through
this whole bding
and I won't give a proof but here is uh
kind of the core of what's Happening
Here and here's in fact an example why
you get Factor two okay so there are two
biders here A and B and just two queries
p and
Q and A has a value of one for p b has a
value of almost one for Q and then
there's this cross Edge where a has a
little bit of value for Q okay if you
give it to me I'll get a value of
Epsilon well B doesn't care about P atop
right so like for folks who work on
online matching this is the classic kind
of Z graph think about um and what we
would like to do is give P to A and Q to
B because that's the highest value
bidder for that item and let's say both
the targets are one so they are kind of
equally
weighted right and so your optimal
efficiency would be uh two minus
Epsilon but instead in this bidding
under second price
auction a has an in kind of A's optimal
bid is to put a very high multiplier on
its
value so that you bid one for p and you
bid one I'm sorry you bid like very high
number for p one/
Epsilon and you bid basically Epsilon
Time 1 over Epsilon so you bid one for
Q while B just bids its value because it
only has this one item to bid so a in
some sense is bidding proportional to
its value for the entire
bundle and now under a second price
auction p is basically free for a
because there's no competition there so
bidding a high number doesn't matter and
then it's getting a value of one for a
cost of zero over
here and therefore it can afford to
spend one to grab this item Q from
B uh and still be within its Target
constraint because the value would be uh
value would be about one and the cost
would be about one so it gets a little
bit more uh through this bidding system
and both the items go to a and so the
value actually is just 1 plus Epsilon
and that's how you get this price of
Anarchy of
two yeah this is what I said a gets P
for basically free which enables a high
bid for Q and that's essentially what's
happening when then you can prove the
factor of
two okay so now the kind of the rest of
the uh questions we ask is can we
improve over vcg I mean it's already
kind of surprising maybe in some sense
that vcg is not the most efficient
auction but that's simply an artifact of
the uh the objective functions here it's
not because I
linear so can another prior free auction
lead to better welfare in
equilibrium or is half the best you can
hope for so that's the question we
address next and prior free basically
means the auction only works on the bids
without any kind of extra information
like a bean prior
or like a second price or first
price so now for the rest of the talk
I'll talk about uh improving the
equilibrium
Weare uh through different auction
designs and so in oh I didn't so in
another paper um in uh dub
22 proved that uh there is a truthful
auction is a randomized we'll call it
Rand with two parameters Alpha and P
which achieves a better price of
Anarchy for the case of two
biders better by a little bit 1.89 but
it's interesting that it can beat uh
beat that bound of
two and then we also prove that uh no
truthful op
can achieve better than two if the
number of biders grows to
Infinity if the competition is very
intense then uh then you cannot beat two
but with low competition you can
actually beat two and do better than
second
price and here is here's the randomized
aution it's kind of Pretty Natural so
we'll call it Rand and I said there's
another parameter P but for this I just
fix that to be oneir so you have two
biders there's a higher bidder and lower
bidder in this auction
fun um if the higher bidder beats the
lower bidder's bid by a factor of alpha
so with a margin then it wins and
otherwise if the bids are within a
margin then we'll do a lottery but with
the bias towards the higher
bidder
okay so if you beat by a margin then you
get with probability one if you're
within margin then you get with
probability 2/3 and with probability 1/3
the lower bidder
wins and then the pricing will be uh
whatever natural truthful pricing falls
out of
this uh this illustrates the uh this
auction for two biders where the second
price auction this is the other bidder's
Bid And this xaxis is your bid the
second price auction you don't win if
you're lower and then you win the entire
item if you're are higher and this is
kind of a smoother allocation function
so you start winning when you're within
a margin and then you win uh with higher
probability and then you win for
sure what's the intuition here like uh
can think of it as it's a fair
allocation and Loosely used term that
well if the bids were equal then you IDE
really want to randomize 50/50 and this
is like a smooth extrapolation of
that um and you can think of other such
randomized schemes like for example
comparing with a course lens so if the
two bids are within a margin I'm going
to think of it as 50/50 otherwise
there's a winner and they such a thing
will give similar similar
results okay so again I won't go into
the proof of that like theorem but
coming back to this example right this
is the example that kind of failed or
the worst example for second price where
uh bider a was getting P for free
getting a lot of value there so it could
afford to bid high for Q and kind of get
that little bit of value from
Q okay so now with these same bids let's
see what happens at Q so bidder a does
get P for free still but what happens at
Q is that since the bids are more or
less equal a can only win with certain
probability two3 probability for
example and with one/ third probability
you do you make you make the right
allocation Q goes to
B um a could try and raise its bit to
get Q because you know I I have bought
this for free so can I actually get more
of q but now if you try and get more of
Q then it has to pay
more and therefore that violates its uh
tcpa
constraint so in some sense like kind of
this subsidization that's going on
across the bundle is uh reduced through
this uh through this
uh and so you could prove the theorem
where okay so if a certain choice of
parameters
um you get 1.89 as the as the uh price
of Anarchy but this also gives a tight
example where you reduce this value to
0.9 and then that's a tight example for
this this auction
now so this auction doesn't do better
than uh 1.89
either and uh the second part of that uh
paper says that as the number of biders
grows then you really are back to this
Factor of
two
um and that kind of bad example looks
something like follow so this thing in
the red box is just the old example with
the Z
graph but it's just straightened out and
then you just take multiple copies of
that and kind of connect
across so is a little bit hard to follow
but basically just a Amplified version
of the Z graph shows you that if you
have many biders all the A's and all the
B's then kind of of the intense
competition will uh will make it hard to
achieve better than
a okay so
now I should have maybe this is the more
natural question if second price is
factored two then what about first price
auction looks like over here all this
subsidization is hurting you so why not
do first price auction well first price
auction little tricky because it's not
truthful and so that bidding formula
optimality doesn't hold anymore so you
have to think through the um optimal
bidding in this
scenario um and we could prove in this
separate result that the price of
Anarchy for first price auction is back
to a factor of two so first price
auction doesn't give you an added
benefit over second price even though
that randomized truthful auction
did and it's the same kind of example
where it's the same example but now
you're not bidding proportionally so
what a can do is Bid zero for p and get
get it for zero and then bid a value of
one for Q and get it for one and that's
good enough for it because it cost is
one and the value is so you're back to
two through this
optimal and now one can ask like an
additional question which
is we saw that a randomized auction in
the truthful setting with the smooth
auction got you a benefit less than two
I mean benefit over two so could you com
and simply non- truthfulness like a
first price auction
doesn't uh can you combine these two
non- truthfulness and randomization and
maybe do
better and so that's the question we
asked in um in this paper over
here and the answer is that for
deterministic auctions you
cannot uh just like we saw that yeah so
so we just saw that for deterministic
auctions non- truthfulness doesn't help
like first price auction but there is a
way to have a a non-truthful and
randomized auction which we can call it
randomized first price maybe where you
can even beat this 1.89 and get a little
bit lower
1.8 and that's an interesting question I
mean this an interesting result again
this is for two
biders competing against each other and
there's another result where as the
number of biders grows to Infinity then
neither non- truthfulness nor
randomization helps the similar kind of
complicated instance that I had earlier
shows that result as
well in this whole kind of work about
matching under his auto bidding there
are some further future questions that
I'll highlight to
conclude uh I focused on prior free
auctions so they just look like take in
the bid and then you know do something
with the bids uh you could have priors
that's the natural model and if you have
priors on the values can you do better
um this result by my colleagues at
Google shows that uh if you if you had
an estimate of all these values on these
edges
basically the
values you could then improve much uh
further over two uh for example if you
had a gamma estimate of the value then
you could set kind of a per bidder
Reserve based on that estimate and then
you could achieve a factor which is is
of this form 1 plus gamma divided by
two
so so if gamma is zero that means your
estimat is very bad then you're back to
a
half gamma is one that means you got
very accurate estimates then you got the
optimal
allocation here's another open question
which is back to the prior free auctions
world what is an optimal auction with
this definition of optimality so under
tcpa biders and look at the price of
Anarchy in
equilibri and we believe it's better
than this kind of 1.8 that we that we
show uh probably needs both kind of the
non- truthfulness and randomization
aspects uh there are other interesting
questions for example we didn't actually
talk about how do you get these
multipliers the bidding multipliers and
that's a whole question about online
learning
algorithms uh where you learn this
multiplier over time through various uh
convex optimization techniques and the
very nice papers on that coming out
recently and I mentioned this a little
bit earlier which
is again I'll emphasize that we are
talking
about the quality of the equilibrium
assuming that the targets which are
entered are fixed we didn't talk about
the mechanism design in this talk um and
that's a kind of very interesting
question how do you design mechanisms
under such an auto biding setting uh and
again there could be like two versions
of it one is where you take this kind of
objective literally saying that you want
to maximize conversion subject to this
average constraint or you can talk about
classic profit maximizing quasi linear
advertisers using Target uh U
interfaces and there's some nice results
recently from uh these
papers another question that we asked
with andrees P Roth
is
um why would quasi linear biders or
advertisers choose Target type knobs why
would I talk about average cost if I
have
marginal and that turns out to be an
interesting question related to the
Notions of commitment and credibility in
auctions that's my
[Applause]
[Music]
last any questions
ORS
that you how
to different strategy
yeah so that's great question if the
auctions are not truthful how do you bid
it's a much larger question there's uh a
lot of work on that uh in this
particular formulation just sticking to
this theoretical
question um you can look at properties
of those optimal bidding and then kind
of generate the price of an math based
on those properties
that is why this kind of between 1.8 and
one kind of maybe the optimal isn't
close to 1.5 that Gap is over there in
kind of strictly classifying what the
optimal bidding is so that is assuming
that it's
multip uh no no if it's a multiplier and
non so multiplier is not an optimal
strategy for non-truthful auctions and
in fact maybe I should have mentioned it
if you have a multiplier strategy for
first price then you essent end up with
the optimal solution globally although
it's locally not
optimal all right let's let's go for
lunch and conv
one